حقيقه ما يعني فرق الدفاع المدني الخوذه
البيضاء هي تسابق الزمن
للوصول للمدنيين تحت الانقاض الوضع ماساوي
جدا كما تحدثتي هناك عشرات او مئات
المباني قد تكون انهارت الى الان يعني
حقيقه نحن لا نركز على الاحصائيات
والارقام وانما نركز على عمليات البحث
والانقاذ واكيد مع مرور نحن نحدث الارقام
لدينا ونخرج
ونطلقها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
الخاصه بنا ونحن ما زالت فرق ما تعمل على
الارض الان اولويات ما هي انقاذ المدني من
تحت الانقاض الوضع كارثي جدا لدينا في
حارم احياء باكملها على الارض ايضا في
سرمدا ايضا في سلقين في قريه الملاند
وقريه
الرماديه ومدينه جسر الشغور ومدينه ادلب
بالاضافه الى المنطقه اعزاز ومناطق منطقه
جنديرس ايضا
هذه المناطق الكبيره التي يوجد بها ابنيه
باكملها على الارض